something tells us is this weird i so  badly  like would love to make out with a ufc  chick after at the end of the fight when  there's no sweaty lips or swollen it's a  little alarming do you want that all day  that's a little like that i don't know  and by the way i only pulled that from  rob lowe insane almost fire after he  gets in the fight and he's like he  starts making out with chicks he's like  let's rock do you remember that have you  ever tasted blood i [ __ ] respect that  have you ever kept the light he's got  red wings he's got red wings for sure  that [ __ ] got i don't have i  ever tasted blood like like like your  own blood nobody makes me bleed my own  blood  nobody  oh yeah when i brush my teeth  that's also alarming right it's awesome  so my brush good